hello welcome everybody to Udacity
robotics QA I'm Mike Salem and I'm here
with CEO and founder of let's robot
Julian Oh Julian how are you pretty good
how are you doing well thank you thank
you for stopping by appreciate it yeah
so let's talk about let's robot so what
exactly is let's robot
so let's robot is a live streaming
interactive platform for robots and what
we do is we allow people to control the
robots that livestream video like from
the internet
interesting so kind of like twitch it
sounds like a little bit in the sense of
being able to see things that other
people are doing yeah a little it's a
little bit like twitch for robot so I
actually started this project by making
robots controlled by twitch and there
were some limitations to what you could
do with their platform so we decided to
make a like a custom one interesting
again so let's talk a little bit about
your background and how you got into
robotics so what was what was your path
that you took to kind of get into
robotics well I actually started out as
artist I was a professional artist for
like 12 years or something I was an art
director it doesn't interactive and then
at some point while working there I
switched over to game design and so I
worked on a couple of games as a
designer and then I left to do some
independent projects so I made a game on
iOS and helped on a couple other indie
projects and once I wrapped up my iOS
game it was time for a new project so I
was in the middle of prototyping like a
new game concept and then I saw like
twitch plays Pokemon happen and like if
you guys aren't familiar with like
twitch or twitch plays Pokemon like
somebody hooked up the game Pokemon to
twitch TV which is like a live streaming
service and people were able to play the
game Pokemon with the chat and I thought
that was pretty interesting and and then
I had had always had in my mind like
doing stuff with robotics and I was just
like I put the two together and I was
like haha I want to do that so I
basically taught myself how to make
robots and hardware in order to realize
the project so that's interesting that
you didn't have much of a hardware
background before
kind of starting that you had your game
development background right in game
design yeah you were very familiar with
that kind of process you knew you want
to do something kind of interactive it
sounds like yeah what was it like
learning hardware because I know for a
lot of people for myself included I had
a really hard time when I started
learning hardware you know I didn't come
from that background it's a little
frustrating it's a little overwhelming
for me personally it was a experience
like for you yeah it's it's a little
hard like once you get down at like the
low level but once you realize
everything is like everything's just a
bunch of wavy lines like it's not it's
not too bad
and you know you do the research and you
find things that do what you want so you
get to use these big components and I
think the accessibility of everything
with Arduino and Raspberry Pi is like
you know becoming more and more
accessible to non like super technical
people like if I had to make like a like
a circuit board driver from scratch you
know and that would have been a lot
harder than just buying a Raspberry Pi
or buying like an Arduino kit and just
downloading some software and like
putting stuff together yeah yeah so in
your experience so we had a we Louise
Anderson from traffic near last week he
was talking about using commercial
off-the-shelf parts
it sounds like Raspberry Pi and Arduino
there obviously you know well-known
products you can't come up pretty much
anywhere they're open-source through
their wonderful what is your opinion on
kind of using those types of products
for prototyping I think they're great
for prototyping because they do a lot of
things like out of the box and you don't
even realize all of the things that
they're doing for you until you try to
not use them and and like the nice thing
is is like the Raspberry Pi like in
particular is so well supported like I
can just Google almost any question I
have and somebody has a solution for it
right I mean there's better stuff
probably but then like the the you know
what you can do with it isn't as
accessible just because it's not as well
supported or like you know the community
isn't there right yeah so talking about
other types of hardware I know there's
some people out there who like you know
in videos like Jetson TK series right
what were some of the considerations
aside from like user community
like a Raspberry Pi versus something
like a Jetson which is like $300 or so
for one of those boards so Nvidia
actually sent me a Jetson
both the T k1 and the TT x1 and I
fiddled it around with them so you know
the first thing is it requires a lot of
setup
so like the Jetson tx1 for instance like
I had to have another bun to machine in
order to install the software on the
thing and even then it's even then
there's like not a big community so it's
like this thing is super amazing it's
like a credit card size board right and
you know it's about as strong as like a
ps3 or ps4 it's somewhere in between
there right but it you know all that all
of that capability is locked up on this
thing that you know is hard for me to
use because there's just so much
low-level work that has to be done in
order to utilize that well so there's a
lot of overhead for you to kind of get
going
yes not where I solve the problem that
you want yeah
whereas with the Raspberry Pi it's like
you know I want this bit of software I
want that bit of software and somebody
somewhere has already done it there's
like some open source project you just
download it you you know modify it as
you need to and and get going and yeah
go ahead I'm sorry I was going to say it
and it's usually enough to do like a
proof-of-concept and you can always
graduate to more advanced stuff later
but if you're if you're just trying to
like prototype and get stuff working
like you know you want to do things with
the lowest entry point so how long did
it take you to kind of go from concept
to prototype um about a month actually
Wow was very quick yeah so though so I
did some research on hardware I messed
around with like Arduino a little bit
and I put together like someone else's
like robot kit it was like a robot ass
darwin many something so I did a I did a
little bit of like experimenting with
just hardware before I dug in and then I
decided to dig in so I bought a
Raspberry Pi I bought all the components
that I thought I needed and like I
didn't know anything about mechanical
engineering or know where to get parts
to prototype robot so I just use Legos
so the the first robot I made was out of
Legos and it work
only with twitch so so it took commands
from the chat in a livestream video to
the twitch video feed and yeah and then
I built a lot on top of that and then
and then like more recently we moved to
this like online platform so now it's
made for robots yeah nice so your your
platform your chassis that you're using
you started off with Legos did you feel
that was like an adequate place to kind
of start for your prototype or did you
feel like I really want to get off of
this platform really quickly and into
something that's more aluminum or you
know 3d printed or custom molded okay so
it's like for the robot body
sorry I was talking about like the
software platform oh here oh yeah big
alliance darn yeah thing for the body
yeah I was using Legos and that was just
what I had around right and we you know
we there's no platform you know for
live-streaming besides twitch at the
time like there was no Facebook wide yet
there was no beam Pro yet like none of
those sites even existed like when I
started doing this and I'm those of all
like bubbled up like during the course
of like developing this stuff
so I know you've had these robots here
you've been here for about 30 minutes or
so with you've been running this one
around the office quite a bit it's
pretty great so I want you to kind of
talk talk me through this robot a little
bit if you don't mind okay it kind of
explains some of the hardware that's on
here sure maybe your software stack
talked a little bit about some of the
limitations that you see with your
current platform that you'd kind of like
to see enhanced maybe going forward and
we then move into maybe your community
and kind of talk about the community
around this as well sure yeah
so these robots are both kind of
prototypes of what I call the tele bot
model and tele bot is basically a robot
that's designed for live streaming to
the internet and for user control so
like a few important features that it
has is you know has the text-to-speech
which you were witnessing earlier it was
hilarious the people online can converse
with you and it has a microphone so they
can hear you back obviously it has a
camera on the front of it and
that runs through a raspberry pie and
right now we're doing compression with
ffmpeg and that goes back to the server
they have the RGB LEDs on the front and
in a previous iteration like those were
all user controlled as well and we'll
get those controls back soon and and
yeah they use they both use
microcontrollers I think they both have
pin C's in them which is a kind of a
Arduino type device and yeah so it's
like a microcontroller Raspberry Pi and
then they both have independent Wi-Fi
cards because I always have a lot of
trouble with the Raspberry Pi is Wi-Fi
sure on board and big lithium-ion
batteries they both have grippers so
they can get into trouble yes we Adam
running around untying people shoelaces
yes I'm tying shoelaces quite a lot of
fun than watching actually yanking cords
off desks yeah grabbing tows they all
they like to do those things so I'm
assuming when you first started this or
even now you probably test a lot of
these things at home what kind of
trouble have you seen when you open them
up for people to play with like what
kind of situations are you like oh no I
didn't I didn't expect it to go over and
grab this wire you know I lost the lamp
off of the table or well I mean robot
proofy in your house is a little bit
like childproof Venus so like you have
to you know whatever whatever they can
mess with they'll mess with so cords you
know you got to make sure what's ever on
the ground they can't do it like if I
have them on in my house like you know
I'll be looking for my shoes and the
shoes will be stuffed like ones under
the bed like ones under the couch and
like my co-founder Rick there was an
incident where like he had some
important documents that they managed to
grab off a desk because one of his
robots had a big arm I was able to like
reach in and pull some stuff and then
pull the documents off and then it went
and he's at work well this is happening
so he left live at home yeah it's like a
dog at that yeah actually has like a
group of four robots that are always on
in his house so yeah and he went and
there's a video on YouTube of this too
and he you know
and the robot just like drops the
documents in the toilet because they can
so yeah they'll both get into trouble I
mean it's in you but you've got to just
be aware that you know there's people
controlling them so they'll do whatever
they can do usually yeah interesting
it's actually really funny
I can't imagine coming home and having
four robots roaming around my house and
realize nothing is where I had left so
um talking about I know you mentioned
earlier for your video you talk about
ffmpeg mm-hmm just curious how many
frames per second are you able to pull
from um actually I actually don't know
that number so that we're it's probably
20 to 30 frames it could be more like
I've done some tests myself where we get
up to 60 frames and like like I like the
new technology like the we just sort of
switched technologies on these robots so
and since I'm working with like proper
engineers now they they know all the
things so yeah I don't I don't know I
think it I think it's around 30 right
now okay great and you mentioned also
you had some spotty issues with
raspberry PI's Wi-Fi that seem to be a
common theme with most people and who
end up using you know Wi-Fi built inside
of the raspberry pi yeah which kind of
which channels are you using for Wi-Fi
are using N or using AC or right so I
find that if you're especially in the
Silicon Valley or San Francisco where I
live 2.4 gigahertz is mostly just
slammed yeah no good in it yeah and
you'll usually so I have dual band Wi-Fi
cards on both these robots and then the
other problem the Raspberry Pi has aside
from the fact that the Wi-Fi on board is
a little weak is I am I don't know if
it's fixed now but I know at some point
it had a lot of problems with like
Network logic too so it would also get
really confused if you were in an area
with a lot of SS IDs so I found that
just using like an independent like a
Wi-Fi module like there's these like a
little thing called like a tp-link 150
so it's like a little personal why
fire router and it's powered by USB and
so you can actually just take a card
like that and that'll handle all the
internet stuff and you just ethernet it
into the PI and that that's been way
more stable than anything else that I've
used that's good to know yeah so I mean
that that one's a little older some
newer ones that I wish I could remember
what they are off the top of my head but
there's a yeah you just look up like
personal Wi-Fi router portable something
and you'll you'll find something ok yeah
very cool so I will talk about your
gripper a little bit because it's
actually really sturdy yeah how many
pounds can your gripper hold do you know
it depends on the servo okay uh so I'd
like you could put a high-torque servo
in there like I have a couple of like
much stronger robots and you even though
we might be using like the same hardware
like if you just have a servo that has
like ten times more torque like these
guys can grab a couple pounds definitely
carry a coke can
yeah and forth yeah they can carry you
coke can they can carry a shoe okay as
you've discovered sometimes probably
small animals yeah that kind of that
kind of thing and definitely documents
from a from a paper only document yes so
talking about kind of going back to that
story about the documents on the desk
and having four robots kind of roaming
around also dolphins I just can't get
this this vision out of my head of just
seeing these robots just running around
picking things up and throwing them in
different places what's a typical charge
like I'm one of those robots so we have
robots that sort of work at various
levels so Rick's robots have giant
batteries in them so they run like
twenty-something hours oh wow they can
self charge so he has like docking
stations there okay great so they can
just like go to sleep and dock these
things will last between 6 & 8 hours and
then we're actually making a prototype
that we're going to be selling online in
fact we we have a small number of
prototypes that we for telly bought that
you can buy online right now for $2.99
and those have those will last like a
few like three or four hours wow that's
pretty good charge yeah and they're tiny
too there lay
even smaller than these these robots
yeah interesting so let's talk a little
bit about your your software stack that
you have built into these things and so
you're using a Raspberry Pi so my guess
is you're obviously running some form of
a Linux platform
yeah we're using raspbian okay so you
are using just the standard raspbian you
didn't go with an Ubuntu machine
matéo no 1404 1604 LTS or anything like
that now there's like a specific
distribution of raspbian we're sort of
locked into right now and I think that's
just because ffmpeg hasn't been updated
to the latest distro so you have to look
at the documentation on the site and
that should have it listed there but
aside from that yes so you're using an
external or like a USB camera versus a
the Raspberry Pi camera or you can use
either one and I use four as by camps
mostly because they're nice right a lot
of functionality yeah lower level
functionality yeah so interesting great
are you using Ross or anything like that
or what kind of messaging systems are
you using
there's no Ross the robot internal logic
is actually very simple since they're
all user controlled there they don't
have to have a whole lot of logic you
know internally so it's just like a
simple serial USB connection from the
Raspberry Pi to the microcontroller and
that's about the only interface we have
right now oh wow yes nice and simple
yeah easier to debug right yeah and then
the Raspberry Pi and that's what talks
to the server gotcha yeah so talking a
little bit about your community and how
the games are played can you talk a
little bit through like your some of
your typical scenarios outside of like
your house and maybe people stealing
your shoes or throwing away expensive
and important documents sure um so when
I actually started let's robot my goal
was to make like the world's first live
interactive show and I thought like
robots would be a good way to do that
and that's why I started on twitch and
um and I was streaming the robots a lot
to twitch and like a lot of the early
things that I would do is you know since
my background is games like I started
making like dungeons at a cardboard and
foam
living room for like the robots to
explore and play with and I had like
stories and quests and like other other
robot characters that like run around
and so we had you know we still have
people even though it's been kind of a
year or more since I've done that aspect
of it like we still have people who are
like big fans of that and like the
characters and stuff like that that we
used and I don't know like the the
community has actually been pretty nice
like I was expecting a lot more chaos
and you know you always get the
occasional like person that comes in and
you know curses a bunch and you know
just tries to sort of you know troll
everyone but it's not that hard to weed
it out and you know as I guess as long
as you deal with it quickly it usually
doesn't get too bad right um but yeah it
and the community's been great they've
been really supportive like my I've got
to know in a lot of people personally
because I was like I said I was
streaming to twitch before and so I'm a
partnered stream or on Twitch as well
and we have like we have like several
thousand followers on there and
subscribers and stuff like that and yeah
there's some pretty cool people very
cool yeah so talking about your dungeon
kind of theme that you have is it all I
think all roughly the same type of robot
or do you have different types of robots
in there we had different skills that
they had to work together and kind of
collaborate yeah so the first two robots
I made had different different tools so
one of them had like a hacky sword arm
the other one had like a gripper so I
would try to make little puzzles that
they'd have to do together and
coordinate and they spend about half
their time actually kind of playing
along on the other half trying to escape
and destroy everything
so you yeah I guess you've got to take
that into account but yeah like the
ideas you know you can I mean any
anything a robot any kind of robot
pretty much like we want to be able to
just like hook hook hook stuff up like
bipedal robots like complicated Mars
rover type things or you know simple
things that aren't too much different
than a Roomba sure so it sounds like
your model is more or less the robots
are an important piece of the model but
there's still a big
overarching theme which is being able to
control things and have user engagement
kind of as you move forward yeah so the
idea is that we wanted to make life
streaming interactive and physic like
you know like actual interactive and
physical right so instead of just
watching somebody so you know you're the
paradigm like up until more recently has
been I just sit and content comes at my
face you know from a TV right right it's
it's one way and maybe at first you
could write in you could call in there's
a studio audience right and then like
when the internet came around like you
have like you know game shows and new
shows that try to you know have their
own like social media pages or like hey
tweet us and we'll read your tweet on
the air right but what I see and and
even and even though we have like live
streaming services that have popped up
from like Facebook and from Twitter and
you know all these other places it's
still kind of that paradigm even though
we have these computers that are
interactive right and you can have a
conversation right right and you can do
more than just watch you can participate
so we want we want to enable that like
we want that we want that like content
you know to be a two-way conversation
between you and like whatever you're
watching or whatever you're doing so
instead of like reading tweets on the
air right like a news van could pull up
and it has like a bunch of robots in it
and you could just set them down and
like let people just see what's going on
like what what what's happening at the
scene right right like that kind of
stuff it's really cool so if I were on
the other side of this let's say I'm
sitting at home and I'm on my computer
I'm like I want to log into one of your
robots and kind of participate how do I
control the robot what are the commands
for let's say a general one like this
mm-hmm so yeah they're their life right
now by the way so you can check it out
on run my robot calm and and yeah and if
you go there you'll see you'll it'll
land you on one of the robots that's
live and then there's usually basic
controls like forward back left right
and you can use like the arrow keys to
someone to make games wsad or well we
use the we use that
yeah we use the arrow keys we use the
keyboard letters to chat okay yeah I got
you just adjust to keep it easy in there
there's like we can put a bunch of
custom buttons at the top and this is
all like super early prototype by the
way so like things are still very very
much loosey-goosey
um but yeah like you can add a lot of
different buttons it doesn't just have
to be basic controls like we've hooked
up like robot arms like I one of the
robots that I have at home is like kind
of a Mars rover replica and it has like
a lot of different things that it can do
and you know all you do is you press a
button and watch the robot do stuff and
you know and then we're also working on
tools to aggregate everyone's input so
if you get like a lot of people on one
robot like you know it's still kind of a
fun and interesting experience and I can
still influence like what's going on
yeah that was one of the things I was
going to ask you is I'm sure there's a
lot of people logging into a single
robot at one time what's that process
kind of like you do is it something like
somebody's trying to move the robot
forward someone else is trying to turn
it and it's just yeah crazy or is it
more like you have a set you know you
have five seconds with this robot do
whatever you want to do and then it
moves to the next person it's actually
all of the above so it's up to whoever
like so instead of a broadcaster we call
them like Robo casters and it's up to
the Robo caster like what kind of stuff
they want to allow users to do our tools
are very limited right now but if you
want to open it up to just like one
person or a close group of friends
that's one thing and but we also want to
be able to accommodate like 10,000
people being on a robot because for us
that's the way the platform scale right
right
and like as a game designer like I have
you know we've we've developed a lot of
different control methods and we're
going to implement something soon that I
think will work really well for that so
you keep mentioning your game design
background how crucial do you feel it is
to have that game design background when
you started this did you feel that
that's something that you could have
kind of picked up along the way or did
you feel like that's a really core like
fundamental piece that's a core
fundamental
peace - like how I think about the world
sure and like what what I do in the kind
of stuff I'm interested in when I when I
started as an artist like I didn't
realize like at the you know cuz I was
into video games and I didn't have a
computer and I played video games and
I'm like all these games are pretty like
you know most of making a game is the
art and the story and stuff like that
and then and then you you know you get a
job and like you start to learn like how
all of this stuff actually works on you
and you're like oh you know what
like I actually want to do that like
that's but you know this is cool but
that's that actually is more to the meat
of what I want to do and so like I'm
always thinking about just like how
people like use things and how people
would or react to things and stuff like
that which gives me a lot of anxiety too
but you know it's it's just sort of a
mode of like how I you know operate
right right and and yeah I think it's
important like when going into this
project because I think I'm pretty sure
like at the time and that started to
change a lot as well as there weren't
hardly any game designers working in
robotics right and like you know
companies are starting to you know
target those people you know for
consumer based robotics now because of
AR and all the interactive stuff that's
starting to bubble up so III think it
was a good key differentiator in the
beginning like if you have a game
designer working with this robotics
company like you know it's gonna be
different
mm-hmm it's something I see kind of time
and time again when I see some of these
new companies and these innovative and
creative companies kind of coming out if
someone has some really specific donate
domain knowledge that may or may not be
directly applicable the robots at the
time but with a little modification all
of a sudden opens up this whole new
world which it sounds like basically
what you've done here right with using
your game design background you're
actually able to kind of come up with a
new idea a new way of interacting yeah
with you know the real world in uniting
people kind of from all over the world
yeah yeah then like I like to say cuz
instead of like a you know a
telepresence robot where you have
like one user should one rows robot like
what this is is essentially like crowd
presence where you have many people you
know and you give them access to like
one experience that they wouldn't have
otherwise so talking about building
these robots and kind of maintaining
because there's a lot of working pieces
here right you have to make sure that
you have bandwidth so that you can
actually have people steer these things
you make sure your latency is relatively
low so that people don't get frustrated
how big is your team our core team is
three people so there's me and my
co-founders
Rick Rick Julian Theodore Lee and so
like I'm kind of the more creative type
and like I have I've developed your
technical to a technical to yet downplay
that right yeah so I do a lot of things
because I have to do them but it's not
necessarily like my like core skill set
and so it's it's you know and like
Rick's working on like a lot of the the
robot software and CEOs working on a lot
of the server-side stuff and then we
also have like kind of people who like
helped out quite a bit and it you know
if we get some money we'll probably want
to hire a couple of them for real for
realsies and there's probably a you know
three or four people who contribute to
the project otherwise on a regular basis
now when you say contribute you mean
people is it like an open-source portion
of this or is it more closed most of it
as open-source actually so we mean the
only thing that like we maintain that's
a little closed off is the the server
side stuff right but like the plans for
the robots the software that runs them
that's all open source like I even hat
we even have like CAD models of stuff
online so pretty much anything like that
we can open up we're trying to open up
and making things accessible and easy
for people and how do you feel that's
been as part of your business model kind
of going forward you feel it's been a
really great thing allowing you to get a
lot of work done quickly or um it's nice
to see people contribute and I don't
think we've been like around long enough
to know
like as a business strategy how open
sourcing things will affect us but I
think it's the right move and I think it
will you know help us succeed in the end
and so you mentioned that you have
somewhere around the lines of thousands
of followers right for this product what
is the most people that you've seen
online at one time in your own personal
opinion like oh well for a single robot
for a single robot so we've had a couple
I've had a couple streams on Twitch
where we've hit about 5,000 people at
the same time at the same for one robot
yeah yeah and like that that to me sort
of like demonstrated the need to have
like a custom platform that is designed
for this stuff and like word like the
the web platform is still fairly new I
think we have about 10,000 monthly
active users on it right now
um but you know there are those
occasional huge spikes that we get from
reddit posts and everything breaks and
then we have to figure out how to fix it
and it's fun but yes interesting so you
had some challenges that you did you did
some dungeon style work you can you know
deploy these kind of anywhere and let
people just kind of let them roam around
and explore the world if you will do you
have any other like themes or things
that you would like to do well so there
there's so much stuff like we want to do
battle BOTS like we'd want to send them
out to like in the middle of the
wilderness and let them explore send
them out to like you know new like
places and like when news is happening
like you know there's a volcanic
eruption but it's too dangerous to send
in humans but we have these disposable
robots one of the one of the kind of
more interesting things we did is so
like we made a robot that played plays
Pokemon go okay and it actually holds an
actual phone and it has a it has a XY
plotter on it so we could use the stylus
phone and in it's made for out so it's
all-terrain robot it's it's another one
of those Mars rover clones and and so
you know can go anywhere and yeah so we
took it outside we let it play Pokemon
go it use the phone at
caught a few Pokemon and I got an email
from one of the users like randomly and
they wanted to stay anonymous but you
know the email was essentially like hey
like thanks for hooking up this robot
that plays Pokemon go like you know I
really wanted to play the game but I
can't because I have like I'm paralyzed
Wow no so like he was a paraplegic and I
couldn't really like go out and
participate and do all of this you know
do this game that everybody else was
doing but you know with like let's robot
he was able to just like log in like
hang out with people and have fun like
doing this thing that like all these
other people you know take for granted
and like that's the kind of stuff that I
think you know just giving people access
right right to stuff like that is just
yeah is a win for me oh very interesting
yeah so I know you're kind of focused on
the on the gaming side of things right
obviously that's that's your background
that's the thing that you're very
passionate about yeah but there's also a
lot of application I can see for these
things in other places as you had
mentioned exploring a volcano or you
know in a new scene is there any
interest for like a scientific community
there could be yeah I mean like you
could you could outsource some of your
field research to the crowd I know that
we've been approached by a couple of
like sign like research based companies
and like played with the idea of like
letting you know crowd crowdsourcing
some of their research because they have
like research robots that do things like
you know mix chemicals or different
things and you know it was like oh well
let's see if users can concoct like
different you know chemicals and see
what they come up with like with this
robot you know as long as they're
working with a certain parameter so yeah
I could definitely see you know putting
putting a bunch of brains to work you
know doing something yeah it's a very
interesting way of collaborating right
so you could have scientists from all
over the world working on the same
project in the same lab essentially yeah
without being there yes it's fantastic
so I got to ask you can we turn one of
these back on sure yeah yeah
yeah they're both off right now so
because they get kind of noisy I'm gonna
turn on the one with the quiet motors
but let me see if I can stuff its little
USB do we want TTS on or off um I don't
know I think we can we can start with it
let's start with it on and let's see if
it becomes a problem that's alright turn
it off let's play with a fire keep it
clean out there please so when you
brought this in earlier it was just
talking up a storm this was in
particular yeah and you know it
tact my shoes and try to go for shoe
laces which I don't have any but um it
grabbed a couple of our crewmembers feet
grabbed a couple of people's you know
shoes and shoelaces and untied them so
let's see what the community will do it
was having some electrical issue earlier
that I thought I fixed but I just saw it
boot twice so we'll see if this one
actually so let's talk about kind of
what's on this robot um we've talked a
little bit about this one is it roughly
the same same components is it still a
berry pie with TTE yeah it's just a
little bit more refined and like maybe
the biggest difference aside from the
shell is the fact that it has just
quieter motors so this one you know like
I tested this one with a few places and
they're like oh hey the motors pick up
on on the mic because I was talking to
like in a like a news group who was
thinking about using one of these and
they're like hey the motors pick up on
the mic so there we go
there you go
yeah I don't have I don't have volume
control independently for it yet so
we're gonna work on that so I like the
idea that it's a it's a one single voice
yeah not multiple voices from other
people using their mic and kind of
transmitting their voices through
because otherwise it gets kind of
overwhelming I guess it's probably the
best way they yeah like if there were
two people talking at once
it would be hard to understand so you
said the battery life for one of these
is roughly around three hours oh this is
around six to eight hours okay and the
ones that we're selling right now or
about three to four okay great and how
much are they selling for of these two
ninety two ninety nine okay great yeah
they're selling a handful of those telly
telly bought prototypes and then we you
know there's a couple other there's like
one cheap robot that we're selling like
the go p-- aegyo and then there's
another one that's if you if you just
want like a big robot that has a giant
battery and lasts forever
we've got one of those too if you want
to buy one no nice so it looks like
somebody in the when your stream has
grabbed one of the the bottles yes let's
see five points if you can bring it back
to me
so you're lined up hmm too much delay
too much delay yeah that's a delay here
wrong direction so this is this is great
so I know we have a bunch of questions
from our community so let me go ahead
and take some of those questions
did you are we okay okay so I have a
question here from param ROG ROG pura hi
Jillian turn off the voice okay one sake
share no problem sorry I have I'm gonna
I'm gonna turn off your speakers said I
can't see anybody was wondering okay so
the question is hi Jillian it's
inspiring to see you blending creativity
with robotics what motivates you to keep
going every single day or are there days
when you creativity fuel is low hmm um
well I think when you're creative like
you just sort of have to to learn to
like enter that mode at any time so and
it's sort of I guess it's when I was
younger I sort of like struggled with
like motivation but I I think as long as
I have like a good purpose like I don't
I don't need like that much motivate
it's just I think lacking motivation for
me was more like being overwhelmed by
anxiety like rather than like not being
motivated sure it's just that like you
know I want to do all these things but
oh my god like all of these like doubts
and other things and like I'm too dumb
or whatever else like you know that all
get activated perfectionist of not yet
wanting to fail at something yeah and
then you know if you just sort of relax
and you let yourself like kind of enter
that like you know mode where you can
create where you know you just sort of
let that stuff bubble up in your head
you know you just need to be able to
like turn turn turn that on and you know
you it's like it's like training you do
it every day right yeah so you don't
have to yeah I just get into that mode
yeah so the next question is with a
background of a designer slash artist
what are your comments on the aesthetics
of robotics this is actually a really
good question yeah most of the people
we've talked to are usually hardware or
software engineers yeah so having a
designer and it's kind of an interesting
yeah interesting take that was one of
the reasons why I thought like it might
be fun to get into robotics as well is
because like there's a lot of ugly
robots out there right and you know
there's a lot of bias because in the
media robots are portrayed as like these
horrible antiquated machine and well
that antiquated like the killing machine
yes yeah and you know we can make them
we can make them nicer we can you know
make them friendly we can merge with
them in some way or work together with
them and yeah like so there's a lot of
ugly robots and I want to make not ugly
robots great answer so the next question
is from out from
Adam hello Jillian thank you for taking
our questions what do you feel is the
minimum team size and the roles
necessary to go to market with a
consumer robot um you don't have to have
a big team and it depends on what your
goals are as a company so like we're
actually not I wouldn't consider us a
robotics company we're actually working
with another robotics company to help us
develop our robot so even though I've
you know we all everyone on the team has
had experience building robots now you
know our core our core business model is
actually focused on the platform sure
and you know if you're just focused on
like one kind of robot like and you know
you're willing to take on like wearing a
few hats like you couldn't you know go
build your prototype do it do a thing I
would recommend though if you're
interested in the startup scene and you
want to get funding and you want to
build a team build your team early and
if the team falls apart build another
team like right away it's that's
actually really good advice yeah and you
know and start start talking to people
start talking to investors start talking
to angel investors just get to just
start those conversations get to know
those people Network like you know you
know nothing has to come of it yet but
you know you'd be amazed at where stuff
can lead sometimes yeah great great
advice so this next question is from
shenyu hi Jillian is it possible that
people can upload their algorithms to
your robots if right now there whatever
logic is happening on the robot is on
the robot so if you want to run an
algorithm of some kind like locally on
the PI like you can totally do that and
it and it you knows because all you're
outputting is the video and you're
hooking up controls and whatever you
want to put in there is fine on the
other side we're working on like in the
future we do want to support stuff you
know on the client side so if we want to
mess with like computer vision apps or
you know like we were we were talking
about like cooking the rope just hooking
the robots video feed up through like
Google's cloud vision API right so like
we can identify all the random stuff on
the floor that would be fun yeah so yeah
we want it we want to do that kind of
stuff
like making it accessible for like
normal people to use but then we also
want to like you know you should be like
we will also want to be able to like
Remote program robots and stuff as well
right yeah that's a big that's a big
piece I think it's very cool so this
next question is from kadu Aaron mizura
hello miss Jillian does let's robots do
some outsourcing talented robotic
engineers in Africa so Uganda in
particular to start work at let's robots
um we'd like I think that we would
definitely want outsource in the future
right now we're we're a very small team
we're still trying to secure our seed
funding so we're in the middle of that
process right now and I'm hoping that
after that we'll have a little extra
money to like hire a little bit of help
but it'll probably be it'll probably be
a few months yet before we can like
really ramp up yeah I'm sorry he's
trying to pull the cord out of the out
of the wall pretty funny actually she
yeah they'll just nice try so this next
one is from guy Pavlov what wireless
solution do you use for video
transmission wireless so like a like I
said before we don't use the well we do
use the PI's onboard Wi-Fi sometimes but
my preference is to use just a totally
external card the favorite thing that I
found so far is something called the
Netgear WNC ii 3001 and that's a dual
band Wi-Fi card and it's USB powered so
it's easy to integrate into something
small like a robot it's about the size
of a credit card okay and like it's I
don't I think it's been discontinued but
there are other similar like pieces of
hardware that have popped up and we just
started using a new one and I can't
remember what it is on that's okay you
can always tell me later
I put that in our community so they have
an answer for it so the next question is
from alejandro mejor de are you using
Arduino to build the BOTS what is the
hardware that you're using so I think we
talked about this one a little bit a
little bit yeah
so the microcontroller is a teensy and
you can totally use an Arduino instead
they're very similar and and like it
doesn't it doesn't even have to be like
the only thing you have to keep in mind
is the pi is a is a GPU right so it's
running a bunch of processes in parallel
which means the timing is going to be
variable so if you're trying to control
something with like pulse width
modulation right right that needs very
precise timing like the pi is not really
going to work out like you know for too
many components so you have to use a
microcontroller of some kind so you you
know there's things that you could just
stick on top of the pie and it'll take
care of that for you or you could you
know cereal in an Arduino or a teensy
and then like that'll that'll work as
well so as long as you have something
that has like a lot more you know that's
designed for controlling hardware like
integrated in there somewhere
like that'll work out a lot better than
just a standalone pie so so the next
question is what is your concrete
commercial potential from the robots
that you were building so it sounds like
what's it kind of like your go-to-market
strategy so our go-to-market strategy is
more
so let's robot as a content distribution
platform right so you know like we would
we're thinking of these robots like not
as like a particular consumer product
they're more like to me like cameras
interactive cameras of the 21st century
and like let's robot as the place that
you go to to use these robots that live
stream and you know similar to twitch
where you know you just log in and watch
somebody play a video game you know you
know they were bought by Amazon for a
billion dollars right you know a like a
couple years ago and I think that
particular year they made like a
billion-and-a-half in revenue and you
know most of their monetization comes
from you know partnering with
broadcasters and people who create
content you know it's much like how a
television like station works right you
you have your the core group who creates
the content and then you have everybody
else consuming the content and then
there's a lot of channels to monetize
that I don't you so the next question is
what skills should I have to learn
robotics and I'm going to take that a
step further and say if I wanted to work
in a place like let's robot mm-hmm well
if you just want to get into robotics
there's nothing really stopping you
there's a lot of stuff that lets you get
into it early so I started with a robot
called the parallax activity bot hi so
parallax is a big educational robotics
company and plug plug yeah and they're
you know they've been really helpful to
us they're actually helping us develop
our own robot right now and you know but
they just had this kit right that I
could put together and it had everything
that I needed and I learned a lot about
robots just like putting this together
and you know and like you it's hard to
shortcut like you know four or six years
like you know mechatronics engineering
righties and totally stuff like that
right but you could totally get into
that kind of stuff and like for a
company in particular like let's robot
like you know I think that we're gonna I
think that we're going to hopefully be
one of those companies that is able to
open up like working with robots to more
people than just engineers
because you know like it's this thing
that you can just have work with you or
alongside you or yeah yeah hope so
anyway yeah I definitely agree I feel
like building actually getting your
hands dirty and starting to build is one
of those skills that if you want to work
with robots it's almost mandatory yeah
yeah if you want to do anything it's
vanity yeah you just like dig in and do
it and like
no you screw up and you do it again and
you do it slightly better and are you
yeah are you aware of the rule of
hardware which is always by 2 by 2 I
learned that at my first job so my
mentor told me always buy 2 and I asked
him why because cuz you're gonna fry the
first one oh yeah yeah I guess I've sort
of in and yet independently right
learned that rule yeah it's like tribal
knowledge they were working hardware
before so next question is from Roy
Nielsen he said have you ever used your
thought about using your robots for
search and rescue um if that could be
possible yeah I mean that I think
something like that would just sort of
be a emergent thing that would happen
you know it's you have enough robots out
there and doing different things and in
enough places like stuff like that is
just going to happen yeah and if I don't
know if there's room for for focusing on
that as a use case but edie sure why not
awesome so this next question is from
Gina Longo
hey Gillian a lot of our students come
from the programming side of tech which
tends to have a lot of gender imbalance
what unique challenges do you see women
in robotics industry facing um well yeah
I mean it's it's a thing like working in
Silicon Valley when I when I was in art
in games like it was a little bit more
balanced but it's still mostly men and
especially like the three 3d games so
like console and PC is is still pretty
dominated by men
the I mean and it that's just in a lot
of places and I think that I think I
don't know it's hard like for me
personally like like that's something I
want to handle like in my companies like
I want to make sure that you know
there's more women involved right and it
and it's hard like you know I tried to
get interns last year for let's robot
and I tried to get a lot of
you know a lot of female internships and
it was hard to find like it like an
electrical engineer or a mechatronics
engineer and you know like they're just
they're like I want I'm sure a lot of
these tech companies like want to be
able to like fix that and equal it out
and I know it's like a huge issue right
now but on the same hand like it's also
hard to find people to fill those roles
- right so but that's something that
like you know if if that was something I
told myself like at while starting a
company like if I have the opportunity
like you know I want to have it you know
did
how may I not have that be a problem
right yeah I think it's great I think
it's great what you're doing yeah so
let's do I think we have time for one
more so this is from Michael Dwyer you
ever think about the increasing the top
speed of the East and letting a few
leaves in the park in addition to nature
viewing BattleBots a community raised
pool would be fun yes the answer is yes
yes to both yes um yeah we would love to
do that um I guess I want I just want to
go back to the previous question real
quick because yeah I guess I didn't
think I didn't have like an answer for
that quite what I what I would say maybe
is if if you want to like as a woman in
tech like try try to do well like
working in tech and like get ahead I'd
say maybe focus more on like this is
just some idea like I'm not even sure if
it's a good idea but I'd say focus on
getting in a start-up early and being a
key influencer and who that startup
hires and being a key influencer in the
culture and then maybe then like you
know kind of fixing that from the bottom
up it's sort of hard with like a company
like uber where it's like a big systemic
issue and it's probably going to be
impossible to fix but if you start at a
smaller company like you might have a
better chance gotcha yeah perfect
yeah thank you
so I think that's it for today's Q&A if
you would like to learn more about
robotics visit udacity.com/google at
community at robotics udacity.com
jillian thank you very much for your
time today yeah thank you thank you